c'est vrai qu'on a on appelait ahmed
tazir aujourd'hui journaliste lcp merci
d'être avec nous ahmed suite à cette
polémique suite à cette polémique vous
avez posté un tweet choc aujourd'hui le
témoignage d'un ancien reporter de tf1
que vous connaissez très bien que vous
avez dit qu'ils déclarent lors d'un
reportage au ski dans les alpes jean
pierre pernaut me disait au téléphone on
est bien d'accord on fait comme on a dit
pas tintin d'interviews de noir ni
d'arabe alors c'est vrai que ce tweet
est assez choquant nous l'expliquions
quand ils vous choque surtout que ce
tournant parce que en gros en gros et
non parce que je suis au boulot oui vous
mérite revient à mettre parce que c'est
pas le genre de télé que j'aime et c'est
pas le genre de télé qu'on fait ici est
donc je suis choquée qu'ils étaient ça
puisse arriver je me mette ça je
m'étonne de la part de jean pierre
pernaut parce que je le vois pas du tout
comme ça c'est pour ça que tout le monde
d'accord autre anecdote assez en 2006 je
suis un reporter bureau de france 2 à
lyon aucun collègue à moi on fait des
reportages ce qui a vous allez les
marronniers on a su la sur le sur le ski
et sports d'hiver ce devait être
décembre 2006 janvier 2007 donc il ya 13
ans et le collègue me dit tu sais ahmed
je fais des reportages pour le 13 heures
de pernaut geler ou téléphone et tu sais
ce qui me dit bon on est d'accord c'est
comment comme on l'a dit un pad arabe
pas de noir j'étais interloqué mais
c'est un 13 ans 13 treize ans après
cette affaire là qui sort dans le canard
enchaîné
elle mêle m'étonne pas amen amen moi je
ne savais pas bougé je vous dis tout à m
je suis très content que vous soyez là
soir ici cc c'est extrêmement courageux
de venir de venir en parler et d'avoir
fait ce tweet mais juste est ce que
parce que moi je c'est vrai que nous dit
on dit les on dit est ce que celui celui
qui me celui qui me dit et et reporter
maintenant dans une grand reporter dans
une gêne pas douter de ses propos il
fait des reportages au 20 heures
tous les choix tous les soirs et on
parle pas on parle pas de ces sujets
souvent ce sont des reporters à l'époque
on était en cdi en soit en cdd en
pigistes ces deux choses qui ne sortent
pas des rédactions si sa sortie est
grillé qu'est ce que ça dit en fait
cette affaire-là bon il ya la xénophobie
avérée de jean pierre pernaut milieu
journalistique on le sait je vous jure
vous savez que dans les écoles de
journalisme
la première chose qu'on apprend un
journaliste c'est que on est un con oui
je n'existe pas on sait la rumeur evry
donc soit on les aime je j'ai entendu
votre lancement juste avant vous êtes la
copine de la femme de sema chroniqueur
émission c'est à dire droit ont dit vous
êtes juge et partie non pas du tout je
vais poser simplement la question en lui
demandant voilà puisque on alla principe
le principal intéressé aurait eu la
gentillesse dap et on mari et lui
demander ce qu'il répond à cela
qu'est-ce qui répond alors est elle
vérifier les infos tout ça alors non
parce que il faut avoir les deux
versants d'histoire peut alors évident
ce sera parole contre parole de nous en
parler
il faut dire stop à ce que ça veut dire
faille à un sentiment d'impunité
alors en fait je fais ce que je veux
c'est mon journal je fais là si vous
vous tournez dans l'antre soit si vous
me permettez sa réponse comme ça après
après chacun ne décidera de croire qu'il
a envie c'est moi je vois là vraiment je
ne fais que relayer lui dit je ne
comprends pas d'où ça sort il suffit de
regarder les jt il y a toujours eu dans
les jt des femmes voilées d'aider des
personnes de couleur des voix là il ya
toujours eu la diversité dans les jt il
suffit de les regarder et on verra qu'il
ya des femmes voilées
aussi voilà sa réponse c'est à dire à ça
moi je vous ai raconté des anecdotes
un autre journaliste sérieux aux
reporters qui l'ont raconté cette
anecdote à kim avait interloqué et 13
ans après j'entends cette histoire de
famille et en plus si vous avez bien vu
le reportage
cette femme était voilé mais c'était
dans le cadre da da da reportage sur la
loi bancaire la loi educ'action
confiance à il ya eu un amendement
d'eric ciotti doit faire un peu de
l'information parlementaire dans quel
sera mon poste
et donc il y avait un amendement ce type
vivaient dans toutes les classes à
l'école il faut de drapeau national et
l'hymne national cette femme qui parle
elle était contente que ces deux gamins
c'est le sonore c'est le reportage elle
était dans le sens de jean pierre
pernaut un peu un peu voilà me la suis à
lille mais mes gamins connaissent la
marseillaise elle était toute fière et
malgré sa non tu passes patins fichu sur
la tête tu passe pas dans mon journal
c'est ça qu'est ce que vous vouliez dire
vais d'ailleurs et irradie le panier non
je disais que chanter la marseillaise ça
n'était pas du nationalisme au sens
péjoratif du terme comme vous l'entendez
ça peut être là c'était un commentaire
je voudrais je voulais dire que cette
dame était un peu dans le sang se
rajouter dans les deux quarts d'heure
santé parce qu on a encore des choses à
dire oui oui je veux dire qu'on est des
a priori sur jean pierre pernaut on en a
beaucoup en son nom mais non mais c'est
courage
oui mais il faut entendre faut être sûr
voilà connaît des a priori ont peut-être
qu'il ya des a priori qu'il y a aussi le
fait que plusieurs fois dans les
reportages le csa est intervenu à
plusieurs reprises dont les dans les
rédactions pour dire représenter la
société vous ne représentez pas la
société c'est un fait alors rêve de dire
que jean pierre pernaut a dit je ne veux
pas de noir je veux pas d'arabes ça je
ne sais pas si c'est vérifié oui c'est
ça mon interrogateur juste le micro
trottoir en question avec cette femme
voilée a finalement été diffusé dans le
journal de 20h voilà regardez à quoi ça
ressemble mon fils et il est aussi un cp
il a déjà écorné la marseillaise sa
petite soeur qui en moyenne section
qu'on est déjà la marseillaise
les professeurs font déjà suffisamment
alors c'est vrai jean pierre pernaut il
ya beaucoup de gens qui lui tombe dessus
là dessus puisque en 2016 il fait une
transition lançons un reportage sur les
migrants qui avaient voilà choqué
certains téléspectateurs regardent et il
avait répondu jean pierre pernaut dans
salut les terriens mais regardez d'abord
c'était en 2007 quotidien des plumes
voilà plus de place pour les sans abri
mais en même temps les centre pour
migrants continuent à ouvrir partout en
france
ouverture aujourd'hui d'un centre
humanitaire on envoie quelques images
pour héberger 400 hommes porte de la
chapelle à paris alors ses propos sur
les immigrés jean pierre pernaut lille
sont les assumer complètement
il avait réagi dans salut les terriens
regarder on m'a accusée d'avoir voulait
mettre en opposition
non j'ai fait mon métier de journaliste
même le csa s'en est occupé parce que
c'est maintenant on regarde beaucoup
toutes les conneries qu'on peut lire sur
les réseaux sociaux et même le csa a
regretté ce que j'ai dit que si je vais
le redire devant je le redirai là mais
c'est pas le fait de donner 5 de mon
métier
voilà qu'est ce que vous dites à ça la
question à christine kelly kahn ancien
membre du csa lors des faits
non pas ça qu'est ce que vous avez fait
christine je me rappelle pas ce qu'on
voulait c'est ça fait pour ça mais en
tout cas je le sais maintenant
l'émulateur bayal exemplaires
j'ai travaillé avec jean pierre pernaut
puisque j'étais elle c'est le jeu des
londoniens aussi avec jean pierre
pernaut lorsqu'on était au csa lorsque
j'étais au csa il a été pris à partie à
plusieurs reprises mais pour autant on
n'a jamais eu de grosses censure par
rapport à janvier à pernod est ce que
vous dites
beaucoup de rédactions moi je vous dis
très sincèrement je suis une journaliste
j'ai été l'une des premières noir dans
la rédaction des passionnés je vais non
mais je loue dire que le que les noirs
et les arabes
qu'on dise effectivement oui qu'on évite
de les mettre dans à à l'antenne ça a
été remarqué par le csa que ça puisse
être dit verbalement c'est autre chose
que ça puisse être dit par jean pierre
vernant alors j'étais même si ces
demi-finales importe quelle valeur
représente arrêter s'il le voulait ce n
était pas excusez-moi croire et de
secondaire 2 minutes en effet il a fait
une belle émission hier de touche pas à
mon pote sur ce qu après on va à tes
dires des connaisseurs bus et on s'est
tous arrêter de mentir je les entends du
mois sur des chaînes bravo non mais t'es
trop d'arabes ya trop de noirs dans ce
casting là on en les faisant arrêter
c'est la vérité jean pierre grin de
jéricho et sa présence non on n'en parle
plus trop long oui j'ai entendu bien ce
que j'ai entendu venir il est entendu au
suisse assure que beaucoup d'efforts ont
fait bouclé pas précis que les choses
avancent et changent il faut se dire les
choses
je dis pas que jean pierre pernaut a
feeling ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui même
si elle même si ça a été prononcée
peut-être pas par lui je vous dis c'est
important il faut le dire dans les
chaînes
beaucoup de chaînes quand on fait un
casting démission quand on fait quand on
met en les photos on dira tiens pas non
il est tout jeune papa nom est peut-être
trop de moi c'est plus possible
d'entendre ça aujourd'hui on est en 2009
c'est ça n'est plus posée mais ça n'est
plus acceptable et ce genre
vous confirmez je suis pas étonné on a
même dû dans un premier ministre ils
font voile et le tchad voilà et
aujourd'hui on peut plus entendre ça moi
ça me réveille nos mémoires
[Applaudissements]
oui tout le monde évidemment
j'en parle seulement de son histoire
monsieur je remets pas en cause votre
bonne foi bien évidemment ces je me
permettrai pas sauf que pour connaître
un peu comment marche une rédaction
c'est jean pierre pernaut sunstar la
réaction de jt de tf1 si saddam machine
et il ya des sujets bien plus importants
que comme vous dites le marronnier sur
le ski il va prendre son téléphone pour
me donne un cadreur de filmer telle ou
telle personne qui a des sujets bien
plus importants internationaux
politiques et il appelle le cadreur pour
savoir me filme pas d'hab je trouve ça
bizarre pas beaucoup de femmes et des
gens qui fut présent jean pierre vient
de m'appeler et c'est parfois ces faux
on a tout ce qui va ce qui m'inquiète ce
qui m'inquiète c'est par jean pierre
pernaut c'est pas le la personne lambda
il s'adresse à 5 millions de
téléspectateurs 40 pouces 5 fois plus
que vous cyril hanouna carlo
[Applaudissements]
tous les jours à 13h que c'est un milieu
et les spectateurs
et alors % du public devant la devant la
tv est vrai que c'est pas la nature
parce que je suis basané moi je voudrais
dire quelque chose
il devrait dire deux choses franchement
moi je
en tout cas merci d'être venus ahmed
tazir vraiment où je vous ai tous
journalistes lcp déjà sur ses beats que
vous aviez dit là donc je vous le jure
non mais non mais je me suis lancé je
peux le jurer sani jamais m'arriver
et ça n'arrivera jamais jamais enfin j
ai vraiment parce que je connais la
direction de ces 8es du groupe je peux
vous dire que c'est on n'a jamais parlé
comme ça vraiment benjamins jouent dur
après je sais pas dans les autres
chaînes ce que ça fait cinquante ans que
je suis là maintenant on va vous
chroniqué sur jean pierre pernaut ce que
vous le connaissez alors moi je le
connais un peu
je connais même pas mal et je vous jure
que j'arrive pas à croire qu'il ait fait
ça c'est un garçon à chaque fois que je
croise il est extrêmement ouvert
j'ai eu vous que vous connaissez mon
combat contre le racisme contre
l'antisémitisme contre la xénophobie
autres voilà et à chaque fois j'ai eu
l'occasion d'en parler avec lui et il
m'a dit que c'était également son combat
qui voit là y combattent et ça tous les
jours qui faisait le maximum pour que
dans ses jt soit le plus ouvert possible
je vous dis ce qui m'a dit voilà je n'ai
après peut-être que vous avez jusqu'à le
collègue journaliste qui est avec
l'animateur qui n'a pas de calais d'où
de raison de mentir corp a dit en face
parce que j'étais concerné gt am leur ai
dit yanuar désolation
oui on est touché par ce qu on est
concerné ça ce choc née en 2006 et je
les gardais sa nouvelle sortie au cinéma
fait mal ou terre j'étais interloqué
mais si ce parce que c'est pas n'importe
qui tout en maintenant mais sûr et même
nom mais que ce soit jean pierre pernaut
ou n'importe qui il s'adresse à 5
millions de téléspectateurs c'est ça qui
m'intéresse je vous l avais pas besoin
reste que c'est pas cinq fois plus que
moi ça
non c'est vrai qu'elle a une
responsabilité va bien sûr il est très
surveillée par le csa par rapport à
cette responsabilité aussi
alors ils ne vivent à voir en baroeul
aux sandales noires ce qu'on pense
pensez vous que jean pierre pernaut est
censuré une femme voilée dans son jt oui
à 40%
non à 60% après ça veut pas dire que ça
veut pas dire voilà à quoi sert ne croit
pas au scénario
c'est vrai que moi je ne peux pas
entendre en tout cas traité d'antisémite
ou et voilà mais en tout cas voilà c'est
votre témoignage
ahmed voilà nous on a on est ouvert à
voilà il y en a une on accepte tout
voilà en sélection parce que tous les
deux à deux informations ont du mal à
sortir et vous allez voir dans les jours
qui viennent ça va commencer à sortir
parce qu'il ya un moment faudra dire
stop to pou verrais tu me mohamed
voulait dire un dernier show off
oui c'est vrai que c'est facile de ce
côté là parce que finalement c'est le
monde médiatique un peu influent et on
sait que j'en perds panneau est un
personnage à part les matières monde
l'an 2000 plus de reproduction sociale
là j'attendais j'entendais ahmed ahmed a
raison de dire ça aussi là dessus c'est
vrai que c'est plus facile on est du
côté donne des noms publics du coup la
csu j'entendais gauche disent que c'est
plutôt chez nous promet bien sûr la nuit
voisin parce que j'ai pas d'ambition de
terre bernard ya j'ai pas une ambition
de carrière de télévision il est alors
c'est que j'essaie de dire attendez
attendez à ce que la l'attendait dominé
deux viennent de dire un truc très
important vous n'avez pas d'ambition de
cars de télévision vous non plus vous ça
m'arrange pas eu d'effort je sais que ça
peut s'arrêter du jour au lendemain et
peu importe parce que j'ai eu un
accident mais arrête a été remis samedi
tu dis c'est que ce qu'on valait entre
nous c'est ça
pardon mais c'est pourquoi j'entends que
jean pierre pernaut dit un truc
antisémite ou raciste je serai la
première à l'agonie sur ce plateau
[Applaudissements]